Hello everybody, this is Dr. Kevin Cutters, and I wanted to create a short video just
introducing SEAC T. I know I have a number of people on it, and we are currently in the
middle of switching brands, and I wanted to explain why, and what SEAC T is really for.
So SEAC T is what I would consider a cancer killer, quote unquote, but just like so many other
quote unquote cancer killers, it doesn't mean it's right for everybody. So if you're a patient
of ours, we test you on it, and if I don't have this prescribed for you, then you really
probably shouldn't be taking it. So it does have herbs in it that are, you could say are good
for everybody, because they're very good for your liver, even if you don't have cancer,
or if you're just trying to support liver detox, these herbs are beneficial for that, and
we'll touch on them briefly. But SEAC is actually the name of this gal, who is now deceased this
day, Cassie, who got the formula from an old Ojibwe tribal leader. So a chief of the Ojibwe tribe used
this herbal formula to cure a lot of things in his tribe, and the story goes that Radeh actually
cured her mother of cancer, and then the tribal chief was very reluctant to give up the formula,
but only gave it to her under the guideline that she would give it away for free. She actually operated
an alternative cancer clinic in Canada for decades until she was actually shut down by the equivalent
to the FDA in Canada. I believe back in the 70s or something like that, and passed away shortly after
that, but she gave away the formula. I don't know if she can't care there, but she gave away the
supplement to cancer patients, and so it's a great formula. I've seen it work for a number of people,
but just like anything else, just a reminder, it doesn't work for everybody, just like anything else.
So everybody's body is different. The product is made from these herbs, and it is
kind of a hidden concoction of these herbs. We don't know the specific blend, and that's kind of
the secret of SEAC, but these herbs are readily available, and you will find them in other products
by other companies as well. The company that we used to use for SEAC was, if you remember, was a
white label with red writing. The reason why I decided to switch is I thought that company,
and this company that we are now getting it from, were probably as close to the original recipe as
possible. The white with red lettering label is becoming more and more difficult to get the
order of the company or the distributors that distributed it have retired, and it's just becoming
a difficult product to obtain and to obtain any information. They also claim that it's the original
recipe, and it may as well have been, and we had good success with it, but we've tested out
kinesiologically. This new formula, and I'll show you the label. This is the label of the new formula
that we use, and I think it's the same or better. This company is actually right out of Canada where
they practiced, so there's some efficacy to maybe it being more closely related to the original
formula that she used. I think the herbs are valid regardless of where you get them, whether you get
them in a different product as well, so I'm not just saying that it's one product that is going to be
the key, but I think this is a very valuable product. It can be very helpful whether you have cancer or
not. Of course, I think you should be tested on whether you need it or not, but it's a beneficial
product. That's why we switched to this was partly availability, partly in my quest to just constantly
seek out the best products for our patients. Like I do with any other product, I take a lot of the
stuff, and I only want the best for myself and my family and my patients because our patients are
family. So SEAC T, it's a great T to use, and it's a great tonic for cancer, it's a great tonic
for your liver, and it is available in our stores. If you go to cuttersclinic.com and upper
top of our website at least right now is where it's a store, you can click on it and you can purchase it
from our store. All right, thank you very much. I hope you learned something. Bye-bye.